[Musique]
le patron des vignerons a été célébré
dans le respect de la tradition
bourguignonne tous les 5 ans
l'association des vignerons de Ben
organise la Saint-Vincent fêté le 22
janvier le monde viticol se rassemble
pour prier chanter défiler honorer les
anciens et surtout faire la fête le
Saint-Vincent est le patron des
vignerons donc la Saint-Vincent nous on
l'organise tous les 5 ans parce que on
n'est quand même pas dans pays de
vignoble encore mais dans les pays de
vin notamment Chablisien c'est organisé
donc la tous les ans on l'appelle une
Saint-Vincent tournante qui qui regroupe
les 20 communes du du
chaabisien vêtus de leur tenue
traditionnelle une dizaine de membres de
la confrériie des piniers chablisiens
étaient présents pour honorer le patron
des vignerons comme nous sommes un
vignoble producteur de vin blanc donc il
fallait des couleurs qui représente le
fameux breuvage que nous nous produisons
tous les ans et donc le chaeli c'est un
vin blanc avec des couleurs or et des
reflets verts c'est pour ça que nous
avons une Nabe couleur or avec un
surplis vert ça c'est un cordon notre
cordon toujours aux couleurs de notre
vignoble c'est les armes de Chael de la
ville de Chael voilà donc le Tastevin
c'est le ble de la dégustation de la
Bourgogne comme le veut la tradition
plusieurs amateurs de vin ont été
intronisés pour intégrer la confrériie
pour pouvoir être choisi les candidats
du jour devaient passer l'épreuve
obligatoire la dégustation de 20 Chablis
pour Martine et Nadine nouvelle
intronisée c'est la surprise grosse
surprise puisque on ne connaît pas le
nom des intronisés à l'avance donc
grosse surprise en fait et puis bah bel
honneur ça a été une surprise et comme
je suis membre de l'association Vig ben
depuis de nombreuses années cette
reconnaissance m'a beaucoup
touché dans 5 ans la ville de Ben fêtera
sa 4e Saint-Vincent toujours avec
modération